buongiorno
devo dire che la prima cosa che ho
pensato quando ho riflettuto sul titolo
di questo evento è stata ma tutto
incluso
all inclusive mi ricorda un villaggio
turistico e mi sono messo a ridere con
me stesso pensando subito al fatto che
questo luogo dove noi passiamo alle
nostre vacanze
andiamo a passare del tempo
tranquillamente è un luogo che noi
amiamo definire come un luogo
privilegiato ed esclusivo rispetto a
quello che sono le nostre tendenze e
comunque sempre un luogo e poi mi sono
detto ma nel mio lavoro in quello che da
25 anni faccio questo tutto incluso è
veramente così
esiste veramente quindi pensando a
quello che è il termine inclusione
mi sono fermato un attimo prima di tutto
a pensare ai dati che conosco ormai
benissimo devo dire gli ultimi
dell'istat 2019 sono abbastanza
impressionanti
parlando delle categorie più fragili 5
milioni di persone disabili in italia
circa 2 milioni e mezzo di famiglie tra
queste sono con una rete informale
praticamente quasi inesistente 204mila
per queste persone sono completamente
sole soltanto 200 mila sono persone che
vivono una situazione occupazionale
diciamo non soddisfacente perché tante
di queste persone comunque ricoprono
ruoli lavorativi che non sono
soddisfacenti per loro e non hanno delle
ambizioni rispetto quelle che sono delle
progressioni di stipendio ora a parte il
fatto che esistono anche circa 43.000
persone che vivono e nei centri diurni
che non sono tutti pubblici ma in parte
sono anche privati e che parte di queste
famiglie utilizzano dei servizi e delle
infrastrutture che danno aiuto e quindi
delle strutture che sono in qualche modo
a sostegno delle famiglie che sono
private
e devono pagare dei soldi per poter
avere dei servizi che consentono di
lavorare mi sono chiesto appunto
tornando al discorso di prima ma
inclusione ed esclusione che sono le due
parole che tornano anche in questi dati
che ho appena detto
cosa hanno in comune venivano entrambi
da un termine latino che è claudia
chiudere chiuso chiudere dentro chiudere
dentro chiudere fuori noi li abbiamo
usate nel sociale come invece qualcosa
che apre una possibilità alle persone
per mentre invece tornando quella che la
sua origine e notando quello che è poi
nei servizi pubblici e io ci lavoro da
ormai vent'anni la caratterizzazione
degli interventi direi che le cose sono
più quelle antiche cioè appartengono a
delle categorie di luoghi sono piuttosto
standardizzate allistituto realizzazione
e sono comunque custodia liste
l'inclusione quindi secondo me oggi è
particolarmente o un mantra benevolo che
è un quasi nulla concreto nella
concretezza
quello che noi possiamo fare secondo me
soprattutto è comprendere comprendere
quello che stiamo dicendo comprendere
quelle che sono le categorie che
appartengono a quello che ho appena
detto è fare una riflessione su quello
che per noi è comprensione comprensione
avere dentro di noi quella parte
fondamentale di partecipazione attiva ai
termini e alle connessioni di rete con
le persone che abbiamo intorno
per essere veramente vicini all'altro
un po come in amore esserci vuol dire
veramente far parte di una relazione di
un rapporto non vuol dire apparire ogni
tanto per fare la partecipazione attiva
nella comprensione sicuramente c'è anche
un discorso di integrazione è un altro
termine molto usato ma particolarmente
difficile da attuare
l'integrazione soprattutto intesa
generalmente come aggiustare qualcosa
che fa parte di un tutto mentre invece
c'è anche un'altra parte
dell'integrazione che non aggiustare
qualcosa ma partire da quello che
qualcuno ha dentro
cioè tutti noi abbiamo dentro che è la
parte positiva noi educatori spesso e
volentieri siamo catalogati un po dal
dagli altri come come generatori di
interventi verso l'altro
in realtà noi partiamo da quello che
l'altro a edu ce ne ha fatto il
terminati noe non significa mettere
dentro ma significa tirare fuori dall
altro quello che sa di buono
quindi tornando un po a discorso che
stiamo facendo se il concetto di clusone
stabilisce un importanza soprattutto
contestuale legata alla struttura e
quindi la struttura include qualcuno in
tendenza dovrebbe essere che comunque il
genere umano si includa autonomamente ma
questo è un discorso che possiamo fare
anche tra un po la parte invece legata
all'integrazione è una parte che
riguarda la persona ritorno a dire si
parte solitamente da quello che la
persona non a quello che la persona ha
come elemento mancante quindi una
disabilità una mancanza un'incapacità
diventa la ricerca di una struttura che
possa in qualche modo temperare i suoi
bisogni
chi non rientra in questo main stream in
questa corrente dominante ovviamente
rientra in un ciclopico in una coppia
cavo boragine di interventi che che il
mondo crea ma che non è quello che
solitamente la persona può esprimere
perché il mondo del lavoro
il mondo dello sport in un mondo del
tempo libero in generale non sono
organizzate per poter dare dei servizi
veramente a misura d'uomo e questo lo
possiamo notare tornando ai dati di
prima c'è soltanto in italia 200 e
semina persone vivono completamente da
sole e se 600 mila nei 5 milioni non
hanno una rete in forma
ma intorno forse le mie parole ma sono
così infondate
l'eco sistema sociale e comunicativo
oggi attua una democratizzazione
dell'informazione veramente incredibile
quello che stiamo facendo qui nella
prova riusciamo ad arrivare dove prima
non era impensabile arrivare il digital
device si sta sempre più accorciando
cioè tutti quanti noi abbiamo a
disposizione un mezzo potentissimo in
tasca e ci connette al mondo anche se
poi non sappiamo leggere le informazioni
che arrivano quasi sempre ci sono delle
cattive informazioni che non sappiamo
catalogare e finiamo per pensare
qualcosa che in realtà poi non è la
realtà dei fatti mentre invece il
cultural del raid cioè quello che è la
nostra cultura alla comunicazione quello
che è il potere che questa crea viene
sempre più allungato dilazionato da
quelli che sono tutti tutti questi
strumenti tecnologici che ci consentono
di esserci ma non ci consentono di
essere veramente in grado di leggere il
linguaggio del nostro corpo il
linguaggio infatti non è soltanto quello
che io adesso sto in modo molto
originale portando a voi e anche il mio
modo di muovermi di vestirmi quello che
io sto provando la mia agitazione e la
mia ansia quello che tutti noi oggi
stiamo cercando di portare con tanta
partecipazione
quello che ci portiamo dietro le nostre
vite e questa cosa non è sempre
possibile portarla attraverso immagini
tecnologici quello che stiamo vivendo in
quest'anno e mezzo di pandemia tutt'oggi
non risolta nella dimostrazione
moltissime persone hanno hanno ormai
risolto il problema della comunicazione
addirittura portandosi il mezzo
strumentale nel letto non partecipando
alle lezioni che sono state quasi sempre
in dada in modo attivo ma facendo altre
cose mentre questo succederà
torniamo un attimo alla al paradigma e
prima ho citato come mai stringe le
correnti dominanti
il paradigma dominante lo è tutt'oggi ed
è direi eclatante è quello della
medicalizzazione e in questi ultimi
vent'anni abbiamo assistito al raddoppio
delle diagnosi di disturbo l'attenzione
di disturbo del comportamento e le best
i bisogni educativi speciali stanno
fioccando dovunque
negli ultimi 20 anni guarda caso abbiamo
inserito le persone disabili e le
persone con problemi comportamentali
nelle scuole con un livello di
integrazione che purtroppo non è stato
sempre all'altezza
adesso stiamo discutendo se insegnanti
di sostegno debbano essere abbandonati
come ruolo devono essere implementati
gli educatori professionali non sono
ancora stati citati o stanno iniziando
ad essere citati in questo momento forse
sarebbe il caso di rivedere anche questa
posizione la grande malattia porta un
effetto negativo anche un effetto
iatrogeno in termini tecnici quasi
sempre è il rinunciare a dei ruoli
educativi particolare i genitori sono
forse molto più attratti dall avere una
sicurezza della diagnosi piuttosto che
da provare veramente a fare il genitore
e questa cosa lo dico da genitore mostra
che dell'educatore
abbiamo anche un altro problema non
accettiamo l'imperfezione non ci piace
la la differenza la diversità quasi
sempre non è una risorsa ma diventa uno
spunto di non originalità mentre invece
secondo me e lo dice la storia dietro
rimane dietro di noi è una potente
originalità e può cambiare veramente il
mondo
educare accettando l'imperfezione come
un dono di dio e non come una condanna
forse sarebbe l'inizio di una vera e
propria rivoluzione un po di buon senso
non si tratta di essere benevoli
piuttosto che accettare dare per
scontato quello che è un male una
malattia si tratta di essere un attimino
più disposti a vedere che la diversità
non è la persona che ha un problema di
diversità è evidente ma è dentro di noi
ognuno è diverso ci sono delle parti
molto importante che è un pedagogista
famoso brasiliano l'aveva detto molto
bene nessuno educa nessuno e gli uomini
si educano tra gli uomini con la
mediazione del mondo il mondo dovrebbe
essere partecipativo rispetto quello che
è la costruzione dell'identità e
dell'autonomia mentre invece è diviso in
categorie queste categorie spesso e
volentieri hanno degli interessi molto
potenti svolgono un'attività
fondamentale per portare avanti quelli
che sono i disegni degli stati e tutto
il resto diventa qualcosa che segue
qualcosa come dicevo prima non fa più
parte del paradigma e del maestro
il contesto è importante quindi un
contesto è una rete di sistemi dovrebbe
essere una spinta alla cultura del non
custodiali smo e dovrebbe essere il
portatore dei diritti delle persone
ora i diritti delle persone come sto
dicendo quindi non sono soltanto i
diritti di noi tesi reputiamo
normodotati ma sono i diritti di tutti e
tutte le categorie che hanno dei
problemi ma non è così
c'è un tentativo da parte nostra di
essere presenti in questo territorio
molto in maniera molto capillare con
progetti che sono progetti lavorativi
progetti sportivi progetti di inclusione
tempo libero e ci rendiamo conto che la
non apertura rispetto a un certo tipo di
disagio provoca a ricaduta una
impossibilità di scelta che è l'elemento
fondamentale per avere veramente il
diritto di stare con chi vuoi di stare
dove vuoi di costruire qualcosa per te
anche se sei una persona con una
handicap
mentale cosa che oggi come oggi non è
molto diffusa
vi inviterei a riflettere sul fatto che
poche volte si sente domandare una
persona con handicap psichico
se sarà in grado di avere una casa o se
potrà avere una vita indipendente mentre
invece questo dovrebbe essere possibile
anche per lui con un mondo organizzato
su misura d'uomo per tutte le persone
che lo compongono ecco perché il mondo
unico quindi la novità che portiamo è la
condivisione che parte in rete non tanto
dalle persone diversamente abili
piuttosto che delle persone
tossicodipendenti piuttosto che dalle
persone che hanno problemi di reddito
piuttosto che da altre problematiche che
si pongono ma dal diritto di avere tutti
quanti in rete tutti quanti vicini a
dare un po del proprio tempo per poter
dare delle chance delle alternative a
tutti quanti di scelta rispetto a quelle
che sono delle dinamiche che poi
potranno portarlo portarlo verso
l'autonomia verso i suoi diritti
stiamo provando a fare un discorso molto
importante anche rispetto alla alla
connessione con letta e associazione che
è un altro punto comunque molto
difficile da attuare perché vi ricordo è
queste sono le ultime cose che posso
dirvi oggi in questo momento molto
importante
mancano forse quelli che sono ancora
appunto degli obiettivi politici
importanti rispetto al terzo settore che
è molto molto inflazionato è molto in
crisi rispetto alla possibilità di fare
progetti perché non ci sono purtroppo le
persone giuste che che possono in
qualche modo portare degli esempi
importanti alla collettività quando ci
sono queste lavorano giorno e notte per
fare progetti che poi purtroppo non
durano molto tempo ma poco poco tempo e
vengono poi interrotti e non possono
proseguire questo tipo di cosa
appartiene al discorso che ho fatto
prima
per cui la mentalità politica dovrebbe
essere
quella di prima cioè portare avanti un
discorso che oltre il centro diurno che
oltre la comunità terapeutica e che
dovrebbe insegnare alle persone
insieme a questo desiderio di tirare
fuori dall altro le cose positive
qualcosa che dura nel tempo che possa
essere il dopo di noi
la convenzione onu l'ha detto molto bene
nel 2006 e il 2009 è stata poi accettata
anche dalla stato italiano come legge il
diritto di vivere una vita per tutti e
il diritto alla libertà non è il diritto
ad impedire ea togliere le barriere e
mai ad avere delle possibilità di scelta
per togliere le barriere e degli aiuti
per farlo grazie mille
un giorno
[Applauso]